[Music]
mr speaker today
marks a great stride forward in our plan
to get us out of this pandemic
and to return to normal life our
strategy throughout has been to suppress
the virus until a vaccine can make us
safe suppressing the virus
has got a whole lot harder because of
the new variant
and we must take more action today but
the vaccine
is the route out of this crisis and the
approval this morning of the oxford
astrazeneca vaccine
is another world first for britain and
it's the single biggest
stride that we've been able to take
since this pandemic began
it's almost exactly a year since we
first heard about what we now know
of as covert 19 circulating in
wuhan in china within weeks the
scientists at port and down had
sequenced the viral genome
and scientists at oxford university's
jenna institute
received the genetic code for the new
virus
and a bit like the great british code
breakers before them they set to work at
lightning speed
we took the decision to back them from
the start with funding and access to the
nhs for clinical trials
and partnered with astrazeneca who've
done a brilliant job to develop and
manufacture
a safe and effective vaccine at speed
i'm sure the whole house will join me in
congratulating everyone involved in this
huge british
success story which is not just a
triumph of science and ingenuity
cracking a modern day enigma code but
it's in truth a victory for all
because the oxford vaccine is affordable
it can be stored at normal fridge
temperatures
and it offers hope not just for this
country
but for the whole world like so much
else in the pandemic response it's been
a big team effort
and while this is a great british
success it's also
the british way that we're at our best
when we collaborate with people from
around the whole world and this is
another example
the vaccines program has shown britain
as a life sciences superpower
and the brexit deal that this house has
just passed with a very significant
majority
has helped us will help us to strengthen
this yet further
i want to thank the national institute
for health research
the uk vaccines network the vaccines
task force astrazeneca of course and
oxford university
and all the volunteers who stepped up
for the stepped up for science and took
part in the trial
and all those who've been involved in
making this happen
from the beginning we've focused on the
vaccine
as a way out of this pandemic and now it
is a reality
we need to vaccinate as quickly as
supply allows
following the necessary safety checks of
course and the nhs stands ready to
accelerate
deployment at scale from monday the 4th
of january
we have a total of 100 million doses on
order
which combined with the fisa vaccine is
enough to vaccinate
every adult in the uk with both doses
and we will of course vaccinate
according to the jcvi
priority but today's news means that
everyone who wants one
can get a vaccine we already have 530
000 doses available to the uk
from monday with millions due from
astrazeneca
from the bit by the beginning of
february mr speaker
the clinical advice is that the oxford
vaccine is best
deployed as two doses up to 12 weeks
apart and the great news is
people get protection after the first
dose this means we can accelerate the
speed at which we can vaccinate people
for the first
12 weeks before we return to deliver the
second doses for that
term protection it brings forward the
day on which we can
lift the restrictions that no one in
this house wants to see
any longer than absolutely necessary
but mr speaker we must act to suppress
the virus
now not least because the new variant
makes time
the time between now and then even more
difficult
and so whilst we have the good news of
the vaccine today
we also have to take some difficult
decisions
the nhs is under very significant
pressure
there are over 21 000 people in hospital
with
coronavirus right now and we can see the
impact that this
is having the threat to life from this
virus is real
and the pressures on the nhs are real
too
i want to put on the record my thanks to
all those working right now in the nhs
and in particular those including our
chief medical officer
who've been working selflessly on the
wards over christmas
they deserve our thanks and gratitude
and support
and we owe it to them to fulfill our
responsibility
to keep the virus under control sharply
rising cases
and the hospitalizations that follow
demonstrate the need to act where the
virus is spreading
and you'll have seen mr speaker that
yesterday alone 53
135 new cases were registered
the majority of which are believed to be
the new variant
unfortunately this new variant is now
spreading across most of england
and cases are doubling fast it is
therefore necessary to apply
tier 4 measures to a wider area
including the remaining parts of the
southeast
as well as large parts of the midlands
the north west
the northeast and the south west and
i've laid a comprehensive list
in the library of the house and
published on gov dot uk
even in the in most areas not moving
into tier 4
cases are rising too and it's therefore
necessary to apply tier 3 measures
more broadly too including in liverpool
and north yorkshire
the rest of yorkshire remains in tier 3.
these changes will take effect from one
minute past midnight tomorrow morning
the new variant means that three
quarters of the population
are now going to be in tier four
and almost all of the country in tears
three and four
and i know that tis three and four
measures place a significant burden on
people and especially on businesses
affected
but i'm afraid it's absolutely necessary
because of the number
of cases that we've seen but where we're
still able to give places greater
freedoms
we will continue to do so